all right so
thank you everybody for for a bit uh of
patience uh so now we can start with the
event itself uh welcome to the 27 p data
uh three Master event uh we're very
happy to to have you here today uh to to
say just a few words about the Pata
itself uh this event is a local branch
of uh multiple uh events happening all
around the world uh so everywhere uh
where you go you can
imagine uh that organizers are
organizing uh the T more independently
the ts are different uh but uh all is
focus around artificial intelligence uh
data processing in
general uh and uh the our our our not
partner but uh parent per se is focus
Foundation uh which is the uh Foundation
that's supports multiple open source
projects like naai or cpai uh you might
be familiar with
uh uh the event wouldn't happen without
a lot of uh companies who help us and
people from these companies that stay
behind uh each contribution so first uh
thanks uh to park for hosting us here uh
to Pomeranian special
uh economic space for also uh combining
the whole uh possibility to uh host us
here for COD Me Foundation as well and
Inon uh we encourage you to check out
the Cod me foundation events opening
K venka who's Today's Pizza sponsor uh
they uh looking for python developers uh
if you want to know more details then
you can uh talk to me as well uh
gradient is a local academic Club so
they're uh more focused into very in
depth workshops uh which they will be
starting uh soon in Octo in November uh
so there there will be uh workshops that
are regular uh on GL University of
Technology and last but not least our
monthly local python Meetup piga they
will having they will have their uh
event also next Monday I believe 30th of
uh
October uh we have Discord group uh was
uh was created a month ago so you're
still welcome to to uh to to get into
the group itself uh where we discuss
different topics we haven't discussed
too much but I hope you'll have uh good
ideas for uh contributing to by data or
any any kind of uh uh initiatives you
would like to uh
extend uh leave us a message just as an
ending note for introduction to pataa
itself there are different channels you
can uh find us uh through and let us
know about uh any kind of things You'
like to let us know about not to say
that if you have an idea for a
presentation to uh to give a talk then
just uh give us some
message uh today we will'll be having
two uh presentations the first one uh
with v chanowski from voice laab about
language models the second one with
ukash and from Snowflake uh after a
little break so uh a quick
introduction uh vo works as an LP
researcher at voic lab and is pursuing
PhD uh at GL University of technology
and let's welcome W with round of
[Music]
applause okay
work
just once
again
right so okay um hello I'm V yanowski
and today my presentation is about
language models this is very fancy topic
I think so let's
start so this is I am I'm PhD student at
Dan University of Technology I'm working
at graph
modeling real human
conversation and of course in at voice
lab I NLP engineer I working in fun very
fun and amazing NLP team and we together
working about TR this is
our first polish large language models
created by us completely not from
scratch that's we find
tuning so let's start
with basic introduction what this
presentation will be about so we have
large language model for example chat
chat GPT is the famous one and for many
peoples these models work like some
magic box magic stuff in the input we
have some instruction
this
is written by me simple write a short
poem about J and Chad GPT produced this
beautiful poem it's amazing for many
people
but not many people know how the models
works and today I try to explain this
and I hope at the end of presentation
you will never tread this model like
magic box but something rather than
complicated but known
Machinery so first let's start from
basic definition about language model
what is language modeling and
some this is simple concept about
modeling language this is called NLP
NLP
part many tools like TTS ier uses in
some cases some variants of language
models concept about language models was
introduced in 80s years something like
that
and its task is it's simple it's a
probabilistic model of natural
language it could be any language polish
English Today exist multi language
models but uh language model produces
probabilities of a serious of words this
is simple task as a input
we give some words some sentences and
language models produce probabilities of
these words it's that's
simple before artificial neuron networks
language models was built
from many basic statistical tools today
any language model is Neuron
Network and language models is train in
text
corpora basically it's only big data set
of text it could be books
articles and human Reas text and today
modern new networks big neural networks
like
Transformers with enough parameters can
work like CH GPT so in the concept CH
GPT models is is normal language models
but much much bigger so when language
model is large it's a tricky question
and we don't have any precise definition
about when large language model it's
large enough so I show you simple table
of model
sizes at the top we have ver base
model it's uh not too much but not too
big Transformer architecture model
created by Google few years ago and this
kind of model have
around 100 million
parameters
Lama version two this chat GPT killer
made by meta open sourc in version
two this kind of model have from 7
billions to 65 billions
parameters as you can see it it's it's
much much more than 2 million parameters
and
gpt3 have
around
175 billion
parameters chart GP
gp4 is enormous is quite quite bigger
but we don't have precise knowledge
about how gp4 works but CH
GPT GPT 4 is much
bigger CH GPT is version some kind of
version about gpt3 it's called GPT
3.5 turbo something like
that
and it still will be llm or it will be
[Music]
Elm this is only naming can name it
whatever who want H something clicks
tell that gp4 is couple of smaller
models experts models working together
but open a I don't publish any more
details
about the technical
stuff for Google model to be small
other
today
because B model was released earlier few
few years
ago it could be called preprocessor of
GPT models
newer Google model bar is I don't know
precisely how big is bar but it's around
size of
gpt3 but I don't know precisely way so
this is diagram shows what language
model
do as I said we input some sentences
could be one sentence or P text and as
output of model we have something magic
value of fancy function called
perplexity this is function that
measure how good the prediction is and
the relation is that if sentences is
more correct then perplexity of this
sentence is lower so if we dra to the
model
not very good sentence we have biger
perplexity and perplexity
measures perplexity uses distribution
probability distribution generate
generated by the
model so this is simple language Model
T
so why we use probabilistic
distribution more precise discreet
probabilistic distribution
and if we think about
language we can assume that each natural
language has some rules grammar
inflection Etc some languages have more
complicated rules other language are
simple and some words come on across
together we have some phrasal verbs and
Etc and and if we think about this we
can we can assume
that based on this
facts we we
know that correct
sentence then if we talking or reading
we can accept that we prob we probably
read correct sentence so we
can we can
describe set of words by its probability
we can assume that random back of words
we have lower much lower
probability that's welld designed
sentences so if we analyze analyze big
enough
textor we can create based on this data
set some language
distribution we can probably we can
predict based on this text corpora What
sentences is good and what sentences
will be
bad and language model
learn the text distribution language
distribution by some training data set
and the last point is very
important that every language model
can properly predict only a subset of
language because they models learn from
the text training data set so if we ask
model
about specific subdomain language like
medical or
Insurance the model that never see this
kind of data can
can make some um useful predictions so
this is very important
note so next question is why language
model have a dictionary because
dictionary is very is very important
part of the model itself so language
model only use known
elements they language model must know
the words that they
predicting
and set of this elements is called
dictionary and in other words model
model learns to map input wordss from
dictionary to the feature
space it's because every neuron Network
transform inputs to the numbers precise
Vector of numbers so language model they
input transform input towards the
vectors very big
vectors
and if we can if we if
we mod the try to mod
the the whole language if we want to
know bigger bigger number of
words uh the more worlds model we
predict however there some problems with
that
because it's something from MAF called
the curs of
dimensionality with grow of the
dictionary
our neuron Network requires
exponentially more data to
run and this is a huge problem
so let's dive into it what is that
element of the it could be work tokens
engrams and I describ this so we
have possible two possibilities we use
in the dictionary small element right
letters the letter is the smallest
number of the language written language
letter
and if we have smaller
dict we but we have much more data to
train the newer Network
because if uh the elements of the
dictionary is small one
letter doesn't not doesn't have any
meaning in the context of language so we
must use much much more data
and letters language
model are not used very
often they they are very fancy and
that's all on the other hand we have we
can use large elements like engrams
engrams is a bag of words
simple and it's easier to learn language
distribution because if you have few
words we have easy to learn about the
language from this
words but dick is much
bigger because what if we can
model unproperly written words we must
use it in dictionary so our dictionary
will grow and grow and grow so we must
find The Sweet Spot from the language
and from the dictionary side so we use
tokens tokens is the sweet spot for Lang
modeling and what is token token simple
is
subw it's part of the
word oh we have this
table and
the first we have split text the word
second we have split text the
letters then we have text sped to
the sub
tokens and uh on the end of the table we
have example of bam so it's angram in
size of two so we back our sentences to
the SM part of the
words and the best solution for language
modeling
is used to
subwords and this is called
tokenizers tokenization is important
process of preprocessing text this is
the first step
the language model
training and
today we
use most common to algorithm to divide
text Pock and is is by for coding and
sentence piece of course there exist
many others
algorithm but this is the most
common and next chapter is about token
predictions it's called Next token
prediction
so we have our language model our
language
model can describe distribution of
wordss it produce
probabilities it's very fine but pure
probabilities is useful we want to the
model to generate next worlds to to
follow as our prompts and what we must
do we call we use something simple
algorithm called next to
tradiction and this is the main process
for the Tex generation and this commonly
used by
llms
and this algorithm utilizes probability
Maxes by the language
model and the definition of this task
is quite
simple so if you have set of tokens
already produced or these tokens Can
appear as the input so we our goal is to
predict next
token so we can do it by maximizing
conditional
probability of the based from the
previous token so based from the
previous list of tokens we generate next
tokens and this is simple chain rule we
can do it
forever as you can see this is simple
diagram that shows how language model
produce produce and produce new tokens
so as the input we have our input
sentence it could be prompt or something
like that
and every model have some limits called
context
window every model have some constraint
size of the proceed conent context uh
some models have larger some models have
smaller
context but the
models read and extract information from
input sentence then models itself
produce tokens
probabilities and from these
probabilities we
can read and generate next token and
this is done by decoding
algorithm and uh simple algorithm is of
course maximizing probability from each
token and this are the codes tokens
probability which is on wordss list of
possible next
tokens and after the coding process we
have next
token and we add this next token to the
input and we have new input and we go on
for we can go with forever we can
generate token by
token uh answer to the
question given by the
inut so this is example of the
coding and we start from prompt are you
hry and first we be called
I and you can see Pro the numbers of
probabilities of existing of the next
tokens as I
can speak earlier we have many others
algorithm the
code to
to this is algorith with
temperature
yes step the whole is
us yes yes in common pattern is to use
to whole dictionary and more precisely
this distribution of wordss is
distribution from dictionary words so
probability from all tokens from
dictionary is some to one like
probabilities should do but actually in
modern GP models you also have Dynamic
soft Max so you only use a part of
the prediction so the training process
is
faster is faster yeah yes of course
exist some variance of
optimization and this is example of the
Cod with
temperature and
this make add some noise to the
output because
we pick not often we pick the most
probability word but the
more one of the top probability and this
add some noise the output and some
Randomness because sometimes we want at
model we produce out correct output but
with some
randoms and this is the simplest way to
add some kind of Randomness to the outut
so we proceed token by token for example
of course this is example and I use
words because words are easier to
read so step by step we decoding and
asking model about new tokens
and we
have complete answer I would eat
something but the next question is how
we stop generation yes question so talk
about noise is this the temperature or
is
it not the first most always
chosen this is only simplify example
it's plenty of algorithm that add
noise it's temperature it's top K top P
parameters but this is the simplest way
to show that we not always choose the
the most probability one this is the
some
simplification and next question is how
we control the generation process
because we sometimes we want to stop the
generation how we tell the model that
stop this is enough we can of course
Force the model to always generate for
example 500 tokens or
generate maximum number of context
window but this is not very useful we
want to model to that that model somehow
know that when when he should stop so we
add the dictionary control tokens this
is the easiest way we have for example
begin of sequence token and end of
sequence
token and we learn
model that when he should end the
generation so at the beginning of the
sentence we always add the BOS
token begin of sequence at the end we
add end of sequence to and through the
training process say the
model learn how when it should stop the
generation and this the simplest way to
to generate
text
so now I show you the basic steps to
train Pro langu large language model
from
scratch and the first step is to prepare
enormous amount of text because our
model is very large billions of
parameters we must prepare lots of text
to fit the model because if the model
grow we need more data to train to train
the
model so if we need more data we must
use lots of gpus so we must rent a GPU
cluster and this model can train from
scratch for weeks months it took took
very long because we create from these
text
books we call it self-supervised and we
must create training samples for next
token
prediction and what is the sample so we
create we our model want to know the
language the learn the language so we
must create many examples from each
sentences we
create basic NRS as the input and
targets will be the next
tokens so as you can see we from one
sentence create few
example uh we can from one from one
bunch of text we can create dozens of
examples because we must feed the
context window
so we have exponentially more
examples created from simple short text
as you can see this create
enormous data set so that's why the
language model training from scratch
took very long
time so next next step it's called find
un need it's more fun it's more
enjoyable and we at the voice lab focus
on fine tuning the large language
models so what's the fine
tuning so that we use pre-rain models we
call it prain models because training
model from scratch is not funny we don't
have resources we don't have time we
don't have enough GPU powers
so we start from hugging hugging face
repository they are plenty open source
models I I call areal we use for example
Lama from meta and we can download this
model and start our own
experiment so we call it precise
instruction fine
tuning because pre-train large model
large language model can predict
probability of the input
sentences he is doing very well he can
generate simple
text he also have some kind of knowledge
learn from the Lang learn from the data
set he have some knowledge about
language
itself weights weight model weights
contains some information
but this model cannot follow user
instruction if we test row find uh row
large language model for example low L
row
Lama that model can generate some simple
talks but cannot follow our instruction
we want that our model follow user proms
instruction and and generate whatever we
want so we call M find it's called
instruction find
un the main goal of llm as I said
earlier follow the user instruction so
user interact with model by chatting for
example we have chat GPT demo and we can
chat with
him and uh this is the next step of
training
and we must train on instruction data
set and instruction fine tuning will
teach our model how to follow the user
prompts how
to generate what we want and this is the
most important step in evolution process
of language modeling because we change
from Simple Text distribution language
distribution and we jump to the
intelligent assistant then can
understand what we want and
generate whatever you want in
simplication in some
simplification so this is the most
crucial step for our
proceeding and what is
instruction definition of the
instruction is very
simple it is some kind of prompt as the
input and it could be task for strring
generating calculating it will be
everything and the second part of the
instruction is the correct output of the
model so if we
have example of please that calculate
the area of the
square rectangle 4 by 5 and the model
should answer the that is
and this Bunch set of instruction is
instruction datas and funny is the on
the low level the training of the
language model is the same it's still on
the low level is next token
prediction but in the our
abstraction you can call it new
obstruction layer We Are One Step Above
and this is not simple text but
instruction and
outputs and we must prepare many many of
instruction and it's some problems with
this data
set uh
because but we have some fine
information fine tuning on instruction
requires less dpu because we have small
data set
but and for example we can f tune on few
gpus the exist algorithm that optimize
training or training some parts of model
so we can train at home or small
business or rent few gpus for few days
few
weeks but it's one
problem creating of these data
sets the row language model was trained
on the pure text pure corpora we
download the Wikipedia we scan the books
and we have data set but when with
instruction we must prepare instructions
and
outputs and data preparation is
challenging
problem it's all whole data science in
the this is the most time
consuming preparation
correcting and checking the data sets we
spent all these weeks months and of
course data collection and annotation
because we call this process
annotation it's expensive in time and
Human Resources so on the one hand we
need less compute power but other hand
we need more human manually
work and let's dive into these data sets
because we use very often open source
data sets because we don't have an
efficient number of humans to create
data sets so we use internet and
download Open Source because open source
is
fine but we have some problems because
large language
models are sensitive to bias in data and
small perturbation
[Music]
can have influence negative influence or
our model
performance I show you few examples but
uh I think every data scientists know
that open source
data cannot be trusted
we must always check everything because
we have unexpected behavior of
models so as example I show you this is
from
alpaka this alpaka data
set and we find
that data set contains some
mistake
like and the model from this can let Le
nothing and if we
have I say
around 100
instructions and few hundred will be
this kind of nothing class our
model
can can predict garbage so we must check
and correct every every this kind of
mistake
H gold golden rule is we want less data
but with high higher quality quality
over
numbers it's good point so this is
another example of incorrect
instruction uh sometimes in open data
sets exist nonsense
instructions I don't know why
but but we must correct it so if we work
on the TRU the ma the main part of the
production process was to correct and
find correct is easy but we must find
these mistakes for example areer version
of our
model if the model don't know the
answer the true
generate that he cannot translate it to
other language and we
think why why if it TR does not know the
answer then ask for
translation not make sense and we find
some data set from open
source that this data sets contains lots
of misle misannotated translation tasks
and our TR was biased on this
data we find it after two weeks or
three so this is hell of
data so do you have any questions yeah
um can you use stronger model to create
training data set find to
yes this is quite new approach it's use
gp4 because gp4 is the
best and on the other hand it's good
idea to use something better but
always you must remember that every
model have some bias
some sometimes uh gp4 can produce not
the best output we always must checking
the answers of
course use stronger model speed up the
process but we never tread
the the GPT for as the absolute and so
what if open
AI wants to produce better model than
gp4 creating data to try better model
than gp4 based on gp4 output could be
misleading
yeah yes we create we have our own data
sets conversation data sets we
create data sets
from internet we
create at our own polish data sets of
instruction and we some add some we we
also change some data sets existing we
convert from one tasks like translations
data sets or sentiment to the
instruction data
sets the model is like multiple language
langu so how do you make sure that
we always add uh some general data sets
uh it's true that if
we train model on small domain data sets
the model could forget information from
previous trainings so we always add
General per purpose data sets and we
during training we often check the model
performance so we know exactly when the
model start to De
deating
and that's
it last
question but you use original Lama
English toer yeah yes yes so we can code
through Polish language model if we use
original
English uh llama uses multilanguage
tokenizers llama itself is multilanguage
it's some part of Polish data but I
think 80 to 90 percent of data is
English R Lama can produce Polish
language but some often the model makes
mistakes because because r
uses I think sentence piece and the
tokens is more General than wordss and
the tokenizer is multil language because
they use tokens from every language they
always they
add I think the Chinese and the special
tokens they
are right so let's thank V for the
present
[Applause]
so thank you and join our hugging face
voice hugging face you can join our
Linkin and you can try our
true our fancy little
robot yeah we'll make two three minutes
of break just to switch for the second
presentation so don't go
anywhere
[Music]
about
okay that might be a good
idea
[Music]
for
fore
so please take your
seats and uh without further Ado uh we
have good scage and WF from snow
snowflake uh they will present quite a
lot of insights from the snowflake
itself regarding data science data
engineering uh so that's welcome them
with a round of
applause hi everyone thanks for having
us and and hosting us here especially we
are not from three City so it's always a
nice reason to visit you It's a very
beautiful city uh my name is p with me
there is wuk we represent a company that
is called
snowflake uh I think was not intentional
but the topic of our collection somewhat
connects with the first one that we had
about uh LMS in general because we focus
more on the real cost can you hear me in
the back should I speak louder okay uh
we try to focus today on the part of a
data science work that is generally a
whole cost of working on not very
scalable environments and working on
large data sets feature engineering
things you were talking about so uh we
will do a helicopter review through a
platform that will be very fast I'll try
to uh answer question I'm stating by
myself why the platform should be used
like ours and then we will do a short
demo of data science capabilities and
ukash will deliver this because he's
much smarter guy than I am and generally
I would start with a job because I'm
always stress when I'm speaking publicly
so when I'm interacting with LM I'm
usually very polite in case they go full
Skynet so it's a recommendation for all
of you it's it's good to say please when
you speak with Chad G or something
else uh so generally what is snowflake
we are a commercial product and and this
is something I need to state right away
we're not an open source there was a
bunch of uh Engineers that was working
for Oracle there was a Polish PhD that
was working on Vector engines and back
in 2012 they tried to solve a problem of
a very large scale not only scale of
data but also scale of performance which
means if you're in on premise forever
you work with Solutions like ratas
oracles at the time they were the right
Solutions also but all of these
platforms were struggling with one thing
generally it's not easy to scale them so
the idea was to take the best practices
of what they learned in on premise move
it to the cloud and start to use
advantages of the cloud
like basically
unlimited capacity of virtual machines
regardless if you go with aure with with
AWS or with Google as much of virtual
machines they're having it would be cool
to consume them and consume them
immediately for the purpose of large
analytics or maybe purpose of large data
science engineering whatever you need uh
the similar Paradigm connects to uh
storage regardless how much capacity or
how much of data you have you would like
to scale elastically with your sto
storage and and back in the days these
days basically because this is somewhere
between 2005 and 2012 we don't talk
about these ones because it's already a
legacy but we're under the 3ev Paradigm
so velocity variety volume so a lot a
lot of different data different
languages uh no common solution to
tackle all these problems like pay as we
go scale easily have a lot of storage so
these guys came up with the idea to
build one platform uh that should be
able to tackle all of those and around
2015 there was not many platforms like
that big query was entering the market
and they were spinning out through Zas
and and everything was a bit behind and
they came up with the idea I will be
going very fast with because there is a
lot of marketing gr and I want to avoid
this but generally the idea
is regardless what kind of data you have
structured unstructured
Json par
csvs uh audio files whatever you would
like to store them within one single
platform why because of governance uh
because of BU because of fair data it's
easier to track changes it's easier to
assign permissions it's easier if you
start them within one place and all of
the data can be interconnected can be
joined so if you work with time series
data you would like to connect it with
structured data if you work with
unstructured data you would like to have
have analyst immediate access to
metadata extracted out of those so that
was the idea uh behind the platform from
it evolved a lot into different
directions that just Warehouse that was
the initial case because these guys that
were building the platform were uh
people that were building Legacy
warehouses so from the workload as they
are calling it a warehouse they moved
more into engineering
providing uh
orchestration automation storage
procedures udfs bring your models to the
platform make it a part of data
pipelines uh they start to build a
similar architecture that would be
available on all of the clouds looks the
same and generally the idea was to
provide all kind of languages for the
users because users are not the same
there are SQL users there are uh more
advanced users that ride in a that
writes in Python that use Java
connectors that create
applications and we would like to Ser
them all why because their data is
actually in the platform because this
was the whole idea so if you have all
data within the one place you would like
to also serve all kind of users you have
within your company and this was the
idea
of what can we build how this was built
it's a concept that I think whoever
works with software knows a 3 TI
architecture we use something similar so
generally if you think about snowflake
you see it as a single suas solution so
you don't manage it there is a web page
you enter the web page you see your
databases you can connect to the URL
with your Jupiter with your dver
whatever you are using it's dedicated
for you it uses an csql it uses python
so as you would work with transactional
data as you would work with data frames
you actually interact with the data that
is within the platform that is
structured in the schemas databases
things you
know now when you're interacting with
the platform this goes to the top layer
which I'll be not focusing today because
it's something we called uh Services
layer so it's the brain of the platform
this is where we are compiling the your
python your SQL into to see this is
where metadata is automatically stored
so you put data in we collect
automatically data this is also kind of
a movement
where the the creators uh came to census
saying okay actually the idea of
vacuuming data collecting statistics
putting indexes partitioning data is not
so cool maybe engine are liking it but
business doesn't like it because it
inures a cost someone needs to do it and
need instead of focusing on training
models tuning models deploying models to
production people are spending times or
on things that are unrelevant from
business perspective having an index is
not relevant having a Insight or outcome
of a qu is relevant how fast why what
can we do with it so they compile a lot
of different stuff within the first
layer uh just to autom automate all of
these operations like Ops like indexes
like statistics like compression like
encryption so whatever comes in
automatically goes through an engine
that makes it more digestible from
Snowflake uh what happens Bene in these
two layers is much more important first
one and it starts from the bottom is the
storage layer and while I think that's
relevant for uh data science and what
ukash will be showing you because on
this layer it's where the scalability of
the platform takes place so why data is
uh touched fast why can be modified fast
why feature engineering on that platform
Works how this interact with uh data
science so if you think
about General data science within its
Paradigm usually you would either works
on a very large clusters either in the
cloud or on Prem or in most of the cases
you would be part of something that's
called Shadow it you have your laptop
you have your virtual machine means you
take your data in unauthorized way you
load it to the memory of your laptop you
try to do something with it and then
maybe store the results back within the
repository so quite often the data as
you have it is either not accessible to
you as a scientist or an engineer who is
the scientist
here one two three four five who's the
engineer and five hidden probably more
who is the
analyst one who else do we have here too
data architect who
else what other roles we have because we
have like 30 people and I 10 people rais
their hands so we have some other roles
here hidden roles hidden roles theying
working on Shadow it PMS architects
who students students okay generally so
so whom of you Works in Enterprises not
in startups but in in places where you
have some governance rules in place
okay we have around 10 people
and if you work on the consumer side how
much time it takes for you to get the
data you need actually so you're
performing either received a request to
build a report or you have hypothesis
you need to validate or you want to do a
self-service and create a schema for you
how much time it takes
usually depends on the project
average you don't have it on your laptop
I need to add not sure sure days hours
weeks months maybe
more so if we if we speak with banks
because sometimes we speak with banks
here a usual project where you have uh
something like selfservice sandbox for a
consumer may take up to six months which
means
I received a hypothesis I identified
where is my data I need to reach out to
the owners of the data and then I reach
out knowing the owners and having
permission to it to deliver that data
for me so it's very convoluted it's
heavy it's complex it's not easy to get
those so if you have everything stored
within one place in a format there is
micro partition it so very small files
that are invisible for you but allow
huge concurrency and you have airb or
governance rules access rules in place
you have some kind of Enterprise catalog
it's very easy to reduce that time from
months to maybe weeks it really depends
on the culture we may say in seconds but
usually this doesn't happen because
there are tickets to ID people need need
to work so these processes always stay
but the time can be reduced because
everything is one place when you touch
the data you touch it fast and now once
you store it in the platform you name it
as database table you put it into
schemas everything is there you have the
airb rules you know what is what you
have dictionaries not dictionaries like
you mention it but business dictionaries
glossaries things that allow you to work
with the data you need power to work
with the data so imagine you're taking
your laptop or your clusters and you
assign to each of your users a cluster
individually and this cluster can be
deployed within seconds milliseconds
with the size you need so if you work
with petabytes of data you may have
cluster of 500 virtual machines if you
work with 100 million rows you may have
just one virtual machine and that
deployment happens in seconds and that
deployment for each one of the users can
be individualized so regarding what
workload they're touching what they are
working with each one of them can have a
differ sized
cluster and can be isolated from other
users which is also kind of a problem
that that was happening quite often you
know premises where the evolution was
happening and this was like a second
wave of data warehousing Evolution
meaning even if you buy a large box
framework whatever uh you have a rack
with size of the room you are still
limited by the size of the room right if
you have use cases that you are piling
up within the room as we are having the
seats here you may have as many people
theoretically as you have seats
right so you may say that I'm standing
if we have no one confirmed but I assume
everyone understand if we assume that we
want to put analyst on one side data
Sciences on the other side and do some
kind of segregation to allow some
workloads to run faster than the others
we are still limited by what by the size
of the T and the number of seats right
yeah one confirmation thank you sir then
we can make a data science Meetup and we
need to kick all the data Engineers out
right for example but the idea is we
don't want that we don't want to be
limited by the size of the single room
so we isolate compute from compute and
compute from Storage meaning if you
store everything it may exist without
any to the data but also if you bundle
up all of the workloads you may isolate
one workload from another and aze it
right power so platform like this can
scale in multiple axises why it's
relevant because for data sciences that
wuk will show later it's very important
to give that one person ability to scale
train do feature engineering do data
engineering joining the data without
impacting for example
business so if we would like him to work
on a large data set we would tell him go
to the other room take all your
belongings take your tools and don't
don't interact with anyone else because
the other ones here are representing
business that needs to run constantly
without the stop you cannot take their
seats because we have exactly as many
users as we have seats so we have the
dedicated room for you to do your
experiments and that's the whole idea so
he can do whatever he needs if he needs
bigger room he goes to an admin and
admin says yeah we have a larger room
for you go there one floor higher or
whatever so the platform
scales by deploying multiple compute
clusters each cluster dedicated for
particular workloads as we call them but
also giving you possibility to decide if
you want to have have one seat or 500
seats per each query or per each task
train model on 200 virtual machines to
feature engineering on 100 and do andas
just on one because this is the need of
that moment I don't want to be limited
by the room or be enforced to always be
in the room that has a size like this
one why because when I work from 8 to 12
I do trival things and one with machine
is cheaper and better for me between 12
10 and 1250 and I'm training a model and
I need 512 for that period of five
minutes why not maybe this is your need
and the idea is to allow this and allow
users to constantly scale up and down
where they need because your workloads
are having nature that changes without
today is not the same as for tomorrow
why because you have more data possibly
maybe there were
changes and aside of this one there's
also another type of scalability which
is out meaning higher concurrency but
it's not relevant today so the platform
is made out of brain of compute where
you decide who queries what how fast
what is the SLA we agreeing and general
storage uh General storage and this will
be a kind of a snooze F because for you
maybe not relevant but uh when we work
with the table to make the table
accessible because also data expands
like we talk about 3v what you have
today is different than what you had
yesterday and maybe different what you
will have in 1 hour
and tables are shrinking and expanding
so to keep track generally of
performance and make the performance
consistent snowflake had to find a way
how to make it very scalable for tables
not for computer so if we have a table
with a size of uh 100 megabytes and we
have a table with size of one terabyte
or 100 gigs or one petabyte how to make
performance the same between the sizes
because something needs to touch that
data and work with it so the option to
keep performance in line was to divide
the table in a very small chunks files
are 16 megabytes of size and each of
those files when it when you load the
data is created automatically so this
represent rows from one to five this
from 5 to 10 1015 and of course with the
size of the table number of those micro
partitions is increasing because more
files more more more data more rows more
micro partitions but the engine is smart
enough to know which micro partitions it
should pick when you're asking a qu when
you do feature engineering when you do
selects when you do pandas engine
decides oh you did a wear that has the
IND this of from now to seven days in
the past or maybe where the customer ID
is something so in this case engine
says bypass micro partition 57 12
because micro partition two and three
are having your date so it makes the
performance consistent and it basically
tricks the platform to use something
that would be similar to index but it
doesn't have to be kept it doesn't have
to be maintained it happens
automatically incrementally whenever the
data comes in so it's a very cheap way
of uh storing the data and keeping the
performance and why it's
relevant because when you are touching
the data you are doing it concurrently
for data scientists it's very relevant
to pick a lot of data concurrently and
not one file at a time not serialize
your operation but do a lot of stuff in
concurrent because it's cheaper and
faster uh what kind of Statistics are
exposed mean Maxes distincts uh
cardinality things like that so the
platform is always aware what's in
microp Partition what's in your table
microp partitions are invisible for
users it's just the way how we store
files for your tables you see tables you
work with tables but underneath this is
uh how it's working this is
theour um I'll skip pruning because I
mention it um virtual warehouses they
will be relevant here because this is
how you interact with your data so every
user uh whenever it runs whenever he she
runs a query decides what's the context
for a query and context represents what
are my permissions and what kind of
clusters I will use for the qu is extra
small cluster meaning the smallest one
medium that's four times bigger large
eight time Biggers or maybe it has 512
machines and generally we use a naming
of t-shirts so it starts with extra
small goes small medium large and so on
what's underneath is not relevant what
is relevant is that extra small means
one virtual machine small two 48 and so
on and it equals
power um when the query comes in usually
you would use either intra active UI
some kind of a client maybe application
powerbi jupyter notebook um I'm not sure
what you're working with Deb maons
Visual Studio code virtual Studio Jango
whatever you're going to use this
interacts with the platform using common
connectors stbc orbc rest
underneath uh when these connectors when
you are performing the job they are
wrapped into the context say what's my
name what's my password what is my role
so current permissions what kind kind of
or what's the name of an object I like
to touch so uh database schema table do
I wanted to join and what is the
warehouse so the computer I'll be
running for that query which means that
you can dynamically either rescale those
clusters if you want or switch between
them because there are different uh
patterns depending on what you need yeah
in in Snowflake when we are talking
about virtual warehouses we are talking
about Computing clusters this is the
naming that we have so when P says
Warehouse sorry think about compute
cluster two servers that is doing the
calculation and I will explain in a
second what does it mean so generally
you use you use connectors you send the
query query goes to the service layer
service layer evaluates did I reply to
that query in the last 24 hours did the
data change underneath I need to check
the statistics if statistics for that
table are the same or for the micro
partition he tries to touch are the same
I don't need to answer the qu again in
return I will give you something for my
cash and say dude this was your query in
last 24 hours data is the same job ask
me again like have it for free so the
platform Returns the cash for free in
situations where the data didn't change
when the data change and has been
compiled into
C it hits something we call virtual
Warehouse compute or a cluster that has
a particular size of virtual machines
underneath and you don't manage that you
just see a a virtual machine called
Finance
VM or whatever and underneath there is a
lot of nodes and that VM performs for
you a job select on your table with in
the end picks those micro partitions in
parallel what's the advantage of using
it is that the bigger Warehouse you have
the
bigger concurrency and parallelity of
these processes you are having imagine
you are not working with the same data
as um or you are working on the same
table as your peers you have 65 people
touching the same table now if you would
work with the traditional environment we
go to the same issue which is the size
of the room and how much you can squeeze
but if you can multiply the rooms or
stream it life you may have much more
recipients of the same data so what
happens here where is come to the
platform in parallel because you have 60
p the company hires thousands of people
how large is your company 50 people how
many
analysts maybe three three scientists no
okay so imagine we have three not three
which would mean that one extra small
may not be sufficient for them and some
of them are working on the data that
represents sales the the other ones are
working on the data that represents
marketing why not divide them and and
dedicate them their own power and size
so when you define context context is
virtual warehouses warehouses decide
which microp partitions they should pick
for the query and how to do it in a
scalable way if the engine decides that
warehouses or the microp partitions
change and there are new
statistics it will just pick the right
ones as you see the ones that were
deprecated are removed and new ones are
pulled from the storage layer in a very
fast way now the whole idea just to
repeat it again store everything in one
place all kinds of data and have
unlimited power for your operations
engineering training SQL analyzis
connecting with power Pi these people
don't interact with each other however
they are working on the same data which
means there needs to be some kind of
isolation to give all of them the SLA
they need how you can interact in many
different ways basically every connector
that is on the market is
available uh and if there are no
connectors you can compile them into
containers and throw them into the
platform and run them as
udfs which means that your logic can be
nested within the platform you can bring
your libraries and run it as a part of a
regular SQL because not everyone is data
scientist or model developer or you can
like run large language models as well
right we had a yes recent meet on the
recent Meetup we were presenting
something like that so we can have your
own CH gbt inside yeah you may bring
hugging face or whatever comes to the
platform and execute it in a way of
interacting as a consumer so you have
your model nested as a UDF you run SQL
and you predict something to linear
regression or whatever you need or maybe
analyze the sentiment and context of
phrases words uh you have unstructured
data that would be
chatboard uh recording so what the
chatboard says it's stored as a varar or
maybe as a Json and then use the models
to extract the sentiment using SQL you
don't need to be a developer what kind
of value it gives to you it gives a huge
value for marketing or for support
people to know to whom reach out if
you're uh game
developer and you are releasing a new
version of your game to your mobile and
you're collecting events for every
second and these events are like Json
and they represent some kind of feedback
where the error happens like the game
crashes there is popup saying we just
found an issue there's a bug write
something to the developers developers
can use the models inside of the
platform to bring SQL outcomes so count
how many
uh occurrences of something like crash
when um I don't know I picked the SW
this is a trio example but represents
generally in this case so uh so this is
it LMS we didn't SQL are having very are
very hot right now the market is going
crazy to do something with them the idea
of having LMS in data warehousing
classrooms is not that clear because
there are problems of
uh who owns the code who is responsible
for mistakes who is responsible for
retraining the models and so on it's not
so easy but
generally uh this is something we see as
a wave coming in uh we didn't see it
productional lied heavy yet however
we've seen for example uh llms model so
large language model being executed in
retail where people from business are
writing in the human language and in the
end the SQL code is created and and the
B basically replies with the outcomes
for a human language that represents
SQL so snowflake is database right or or
M multiple databases so this is one of
the languages you can use to
interact so when you have and we will be
speaking this in a second we will talk
about one of the features that is very
relevant for the platform may be
relevant for you also uh let me find the
right slide lot
slides so what we are talking about is
just a subset of a platform while the
platform is much bigger it's one
platform and all of these are
representing features uh we will be
talking about a future called snow park
and snow park represents it's an
umbrella there it represents logic
protein so like LMS and closed as udfs
but it also allows you to interact using
python or Java but generally what
happens when you interact using
functional languages not declarative
languages because SQL is declarative Bon
is not is that
underneath we will translate your python
code if it's not bundled as a procure or
function into SQL why we are doing this
because we found a very optimal way of
running something called MPP massive
parallel processing and using parallel
number of virtual machines to pick up a
parallel number of micro partitions so
it goes back to the early slides so you
interact using uh python libraries
you're writing functions but you send
the code to the platform platform picks
your Python and in the back end service
layer will convert it to SQL you don't
see it but for fact and it's a very
cheap way for us of picking that data
and and converting it it's a way of
bringing your code to the data not the
opposite so bringing your data to your
laptops and then doing something in your
memory we do it the oppositely why
because it's much easier for you to work
if you have access to Unlimited
Performance than to bring large data
sets to your local environments which on
one hand violates the security and
governance on the other hand is limited
to the size of the room again so we try
to avoid this by giving you if you
decided right now I need 64 terab of
memory it's possible by sending the code
to the platform not sending the data
back to your environment was there a
question or you were just flexing okay
F uh I think I shouldn't go deeper
because I see it's very late and and
people are already smoothing so if you
have any questions regarding what we
will talk
about uh please do ask if not I will
give ukas time to execute the demo and
maybe seeing
this in live demo will give you more
understanding of what we are talking
about
generally the way of bringing your code
to platform is possible by using that
umbrella called uh snowbar and it allows
you to compile either your models your
python pipelines into UDF or storage
procedures and execute it within the
platform using SQL or python or whatever
you like
um snow park I was mentioning is doing
two things one you work with data frames
but in the back we translated to SQL you
don't know but it's the the
compatibility between the data frame up
uh Scala Java data frames or python is
like 90% so you write functions and
engine knows what to do and the other
thing that snal does it allows you to
take your code bundle it up into a
function or storage procedure and
executed in the platform as it is in the
sandbox environment so these things are
not translated to SQL these things are
so if you bring us your model and you
bundle it as a file we will execute it
as this but if you write a data frame a
query we will convert it in the back
into
SQL uh luas I think I will handle it
back to you I cover
them do some
exercises Cahoots Okay
so so there is a there is a lot of
things in snow park umbrella term so I
will be jumping into into the demo I
will present you how you can work with
snowflake using python in particular but
you can also use Java and Scala you can
use SQL it's a natural language for
snowflake uh so let me just jump in as
later on we have a really nice
architecture that we haven't covered
this is the news from the like yesterday
that's it's not like intention to buy
Ponder who is also responsible for
moding so basically it's a I would say
moding is the uh pandas comp pandas
compatible framework that gives you the
ability to work on multiple CPUs on on
the machine so it's it gives you much a
lot of speed on on the other way is
something like the P we we there
something that will provide this Panda
API to different different engines so
this is this is quite new and quite
fresh I would say
okay uh regarding the
demo uh before I jump in maybe I will
just summarize something that the things
that P said uh with a short short the
demo of the snowflake itself so here you
can see one of the uis like P mentioned
that you can work with Visual Studio
code with Jupiter's notebook DB Weaver
any type of tool that use jdbc orbc rest
and so on but here I'm using the out of
the box UI that snowflakes provides
which is called
snowside I once told the story about
this scaling up and down and I get the
question okay we know what the cloud is
so you probably know it as well but the
key piece over here is that you really
don't need to maintain it and I will
just show you how you easily can create
virtual Warehouse so this is this
Computing engine that P set so to create
virtual engine you just need to type a
name and press create virtual warehouse
and right now you it's already started
so it's extra small virtual warehouse
and you can just right now start writing
SQL queries if this is not enough you
can just resize it to extra large right
and it's right now it's extra large you
can start working on extra large so
there is no like putting the machine
down waiting five minutes put turning in
on on selecting the machines selecting
the high ability selecting the storage
and so on it's it just works what just
happened so with that simple operation
we just reiz from one virtual machine to
16 in the back and and the time it takes
it's like seconds and also what you see
on the um on on on on the screen is the
name of a compute clusters to easily
identify them because each user needs a
context so needs to know with what he
works or she you have a size that
represents amount of power and you have
status meaning am I running or am I
sleeping the ones are use are
automatically going to sleep the one
that are used are automatically waken up
and and are awaken just to perun job and
then they will go again to sleep if they
are not needed how to control costs when
is that easy to that's uh airb so
everything is governed you may decide
who has access to which one of the
computer clusters you may a you may not
B but you may see you might scale or you
you don't also SC scale or not and and
there's easy way of tracking back the C
so if you work in Enterprise and you
have chargebacks you can hack operations
per virtual Warehouse to easily identify
who was running the cost on those and we
also have the auto suspend mode so it's
automatically it's you see it's was
default five minutes you can change it
to one minute snowflake is built per
second so if you put the calculation in
and and snowflake will do the
calculation 2 minutes 15 seconds then
you can suspend it and you can pay for 2
minutes 15 seconds and in that two
minutes 15 seconds there can be n a huge
number of queries there is a
concurrency you can you can do snowflake
can run multiple queries at the same
time we are talk thinking about eight
but you can it's a default option but
you can change it depend if the query is
light or heavy you can change it to 20
or 30 and if there will be more you can
also use this multic claster feature so
it's a scale out which was covering a
little bit so as you can see the the
form to create and to manage it's simple
you just want the size want the
warehouse and that's it and you can just
go to the worksheets and go to the some
kind of SQL let me just find you don't
need to also always work with the UI you
do things programmatically or from code
everything is configured as an SQL so
creating a warehouse is a comment like
create warehouse warehouse type extra
small name John and that's it exactly
you everything that I clicked you can
write in SQL so if you want to create
the virtual Warehouse just can execute
the and that's it regarding the
resizing uh it's also like alter
warehouse It's large right now it will
execute this query really fast and then
you can just alter it to extra small
when it's finished or and then you can
or you can suspend it so it's a SQL
based database so also it follows all
the paradigms of terraforming uh boiler
plating environments so if you have cicd
and you push down the code basically
everything can be configured externally
so we can send the code to the platform
to be executed and attach different
processes to it for example service now
or whatever company is using yes and
this is like so we work like we look
like the typical database so you have
databases you have the schemas you have
the tables views and so on and and you
can and the storage completely separated
from the computer so if I want to
analyze shift sale like only for the
certain country or the certain city I
don't need the really large Computing
cluster to do the any type of
calculation so I can work with extra
small but when I need to do the create
the model for the whole data set
probably the extra small will be too too
small so I I need to scale it up and
scaling up and down doesn't create any
outages so basically you can scale up
all the queries will finish on the extra
small and all new will come to the extra
large and then you can scale it down and
everything like will be still running
and all then you will be go go to extra
small so no outages snowflake is is
automatically in free of ability zones
so it's perfectly safe we have 90 days
time travel so the data is backed up so
basically you low put the data and and
you just start working with it and and
that's it but this is like to sum up
what spot was saying so what I want to
show you is how you can interact with
with snowflake using Python and exactly
this snow park which which we presented
so I will be working on the tasty on the
tasty byes data so T bytes is a uh
Global Food track Network they are
selling food using food tracks they have
couple of issues I don't want to really
go into the scenario but we will be
talking about selling food from the food
tracks and they are located in many
different countries including Poland in
warso in kov Unfortunately they are
think they are thinking about G
right maybe it will be it it come it
will come soon what I will be doing I be
I will be using the snow park one onone
for data science so snowflake creates
something that is called quick starts so
it's really nice uh and free repository
of of tutorials when you go to the m
particular one so I have tasty
I'm I'm using this one so you can go you
have you have information how to create
contact environment you you will get the
predefined Jupiter notebook page where
where you can run those particular
statements as as I I'm doing I tweaked
it a little bit I'm added some some
extra stuff but basic basically if you
want to learn snowflake or check some
kind of feature how to do streaming in
Snowflake you can go here find the
particular and correct uh quick start
and just start working with snowflake
you can create your own snowflake
account it's free we snowflake gives you
$400 uh uh worth of credits and you can
create your account and start working
with the data everyone can create a
trial for free you just need your email
you don't need to provide your credit
card or anything similar and then if
you're working on open data sets Noma or
whatever comes to your mind and you want
to trange use trial to test how it works
like and you can create multiple
accounts using the same email address so
you don't need to change that never we
of course don't recommend it
forbidden people that do
that employees who who talk about
it okay so I be focusing on the on the
snow park and I will be doing two things
first I will be do I will be doing a
little bit of feature engineering so I
will create the data frame operate with
it do some filtering aggregation and so
on just to show you that it works
exactly like ppar data like ppar data
frames Works basically F said 90 I heard
about 95 98% of compatibility percentage
of compatibility so basically you can
change the import p park to import snow
park and probably it will work but on
theow on snowflake on snowflake cluster
it's not on spark clusters the idea is
here to do the push down so the company
is being B moding what you do in Python
is generally using the lazy method
meaning I'm pushing all the work to
platform platform executes the work for
me and I'm just returning the results
for myself to do plots or things like
that so push down is very important uh
Contex
yeah second thing that I will be doing I
will be registering model and I'll
be running that training that model on
snowflake virtual virtual
Warehouse uh using the store procedure
and then I will create the userdefined
function using the trained model to
execute it as a function inside SQL uh
statement so this is the main idea so
what you can do actually in Snowflake
you can do the whole analytical life
cycle so you can prepare transform data
using data frames you can train so this
fit you can do the fitting on snowflake
then we are working this is private
preview element uh but I hope soon it
will be released to public preview so we
will have the model registry where you
can register it right now you can just
save it and store it and uh reuse it uh
and you can declare UDF and start start
doing the inference you can just
basically score score your data using
that that model and create the
prediction data set and this is
everything you can do using python uh
language we have some additional
libraries like ml modeling ml modeling
is just a rapper for uh couple of uh dat
machine learning libraries like psyit
learn XJ boost and I think one
more uh but probably it will be
expanding uh so what ml modeling will be
doing is basically it gives you the
ability to train the model a little bit
easier so you don't need to provide a
lot of code we simplify that and we we
also uh changed the a little bit of Prep
Prep processing so we also uh can uh do
the MPP processing for it because it is
also converted it can be also converted
to SQL like one hot encoder for example
so this will be automatic convert to SQL
so you can use this all extra large
cluster to to run the this this
transformation much faster than on a
single
machine uh okay so let me maybe jump to
the demo just to present sent you uh
something uh before the times run up
runs up okay so first of all to start
working with python you need to have
your own environment uh I'm using uh I'm
using cond environment and creating my
own P Snow Park 2 environment with
couple of libraries so first of all I
need to import them so I will be using
pandas plotly Json and snow park snow
park just to have a session some
function and window function so first of
all I need to import it let me try
maybe enlarge it a little
bit then I need to log to snowflake I
have multiactor authentication so I need
to confirm what he's doing right now is
the context I was mentioning I
think where you define username and
password it's obvious but what are my
permissions is the role and which
compute cluster I'm using right now
which is telling the operation how much
how many nodes you will receed for that
query for the next query or next
operations yeah this is optional because
each user can have default role and
default warehouse but just to make it
super clear I'm typing it uh explicitly
uh in in the in the in the code so first
of all I need to create data frame so
it's a it's really simple I just create
a session table session is already
established using those credentials I'm
using the table and specifying the table
that I want to load to snow snow park
data frame and snow data frame are lazy
so basically they are not executed until
you will explicitly ask show me the data
in my environment so when I will create
it you run this show then of course the
the data frame itself will be executed
on the snowflake site and will pass me
the only the results so right now when I
go to the uh my snowflake environment to
the activity
I will refresh it so you will see this
particular query was executed from the
Jupiter from my visual studio
code and of course you can do check you
check the whole Query profile for
example check how it works how the
pruning look like so I scanned only one
micro partition out of two micro
partition which proos mentioned and so
on so everything here is executed on the
snowflake when you ask for it as you see
here he's running uh table function in
one of the blocks above while while
snowflake was seeing it as a SQL code so
he had select star from something is
basically the function underne so now
it's a little so something that some of
you who who worked on with pypar may may
it might may seem it might look familiar
right you have a select filter order bu
so additional operation data frame
operation and at the end I'm using the
show so again when I I can go to the
query history because everything is
registered and here you will see the
select from Filter or thereby so
everything that was I I created using
data frame was translated to SQL and was
pushed to the snowflake virtual
Warehouse
cluster so I'm operating using this this
uh this element right
now and so it's a SQL you can write you
can check the query plan so you can see
how it is executed you can here compare
I you can push that push the data frame
into pandas data frame so it's a single
operation to pandas but just to show you
that the snow snowflake data frame is s
Park data frame is
doesn't uh consume any type of memory
onite your inside your computer you you
I run this calculation so you can see
that sow Park data frame size 0 megabyte
when but when I download it to pandas it
actually it's a local data pandas data
frame on my on my PC and because it's a
normal pandas data frame you can do
anything you like with it so if you were
working with pandas you can start
working with it again you can push some
kind of Wares group bu window functions
anything and then grab it convert to
pandas and just play with it a little
bit so about uh data exploration so we
have this functions like count and count
you don't need to wait for it because it
is stored on on this brain level on the
the service layer so this last layer of
snowflake so basically snowflake knows
how many records we have so it doesn't
need we don't need to execute the
statement snowflake will just give us
the result and even if the warehouse was
shut down it will not be turn on
automatic because it can be it will be
automatically turned on uh if we don't
if we need to execute but this this
particular query it's it resides in the
cach layer I would say so you don't need
to you will you can grab this
information any time for free P for you
don't pay for it exactly so describe uh
so you can check the basic uh uh
statistics for it like minimum standard
deviation Max count mean and so on for
all the numerical variables
and character variables text variables
as well uh so right now what I I will be
doing I want to create the linear
regression model so I need to check what
kind of variables I have which are
numeric which are U reasonable
maybe I need to do some kind of like
prep data preparation remove the nles
and so on so Bas this is what I will be
doing right now so I have two categorial
variables uh six seven numerical
ones
so then I I'm doing some kind of uh uh
data distribution analysis what happens
here is that uh is pushing the operation
of calculations to the Snowflake and
returns just uh outcomes to visualize
them on a client side exactly so like
you save a lot of time because if you
think about cartigan Joys joints some
extreme mats uh group eyes partitioning
of data whatever kind of aggregate
functions maybe geospatial functions you
wouldn't want to do it on your laptop
that has a limit of memory instead
you're pushing this down for seconds in
a very large environment just to get the
results back that's why push
pandas well with pandas it's a bit
different because pandas gives you bit
more functions than the regular dat
frame yeah so if you want to do that
plotly or some kind of visualization it
requires pandas data frame so and pandas
resides in your memory so we convert dat
frames and P into memory but with the
new with the new mod modin yes the idea
will be to twak you into thinking that
your data frame has converted into
bandas on the client side but it will be
still pushing down to snowflake so we
are changing this to not force you to
pull pandas back to your memory but
generally pandas is one of the
environments or standards people like to
work with so that's why we don't have
full Integrity with with pandas so it
happens on your client side but with
data frames everything happens on sing
side yeah so I don't want to go through
all of that so uh here are some extra
featuring engineering
capabilities uh so for example sliding
window uh so you can do some kind of uh
Partition by calculations calculate
additional average location shift sale
like row by row and so on uh you can you
can do the imputation with FNA function
with with column you can change it with
am to one and zero so plenty of stuff
that you it allows you to interact to
create your own columns with create your
own features create your own objects
like tables and save it back into the
platform and if you imagine if you are
pushing all of the code for
Transformations into the platform you
can do operations of on terabytes of
data and store it back as a new table as
a new object without pulling it to your
laptop so without wasting time for
moving the data back and forth and it's
very cheap it's safe and then actually
it's much faster than processing it on
anything else yeah so you can work on
gigabyte terab petabyte of data and just
pick up the correct virtual Warehouse
size and right now I'm I did the some
feature engineering some data cleansing
and so on right now right now I'm doing
the random split and saving the tables
for a train and test and everything was
executed of course on snowflake side so
you can see like create table insert
into and so on all of that statements uh
were were pushed to snowflakes also see
what's interesting how large is the code
in Python comparing how large would it
be to have the same code or outcomes in
SQL basically not everything uh is yeah
like this one one line it's couple of
SQL statements that's why quite often we
see people switching to functional
languages because it allows them to do
in one line something that requires I
don't know 100 lines in SQL especially
when you have nested
queries uh a lot of queries nested
within the query python is much more
effective but in the back engine will
convert it into its own SQL it looks
ugly as hell and no one who works with
data would be proud of this but it works
actually pretty fast but snowflak
optimizing that query yes we're so you
can send it sheet and it will be under
the hood it will look
beautiful generally negatively impacting
performance yeah okay so I have the
train and has data set so right now
let's try to do some fitting uh so I
will create the stage stage is just the
object storage for saving files
basically drive it's a hard drive yeah
so I'm creating the stage where I will
put my model uh here I'm using session
file put to put the can you tell what
model doing well this is the linear
regression so here I'm doing the fitting
with the feature calls and Target call
um array so the whole data set was
divided samples for modeling and for
validating and right now will create a
regression model stor it as a file like
pickle or anything else send it to that
stage to that volume that was created on
snowflake side so right now I'm actually
compiling it so it's it's run under the
second because it's right now it's on my
local environment and I need to register
it on on snowflake side using this
session aspro register so I'm
registering this function it will be
called like this it's a permanent so it
will be pushed to Snowflake and Stor as
a normal functions every user so every
user can use it and I'm using those
packages uh in this particular function
so when I press
run it will be running under the hood
something like Creator rep replace
procedure procedure will be pickled so
this is the this is bite code but it's
also gives you the information about the
source code that was uh used to to
create this this
thing what just happened he created a
model outside and registered as a UD
someone working with powerbi Tableau
whatever has an option of inserting the
code directly can consume that function
as it would be already available in the
platform pipelines for reporting
for so you can still on the Jupiter
notebook so you can just uh call that
particular procedure to do the model
training and create the the the model
itself uh but you can also do it from
the from the SQL you can use this call
aspro something like
this so either that way or other way
doesn't matter because it's already
stored as a permanent stor procedure so
anybody can execute it if they have
right
I we mentioned about also about
snowflake ML and I said it's a wrapper
to the psyit learn and NJ boost so the
same thing that I did using this
procedure import psychic linear
regression and so on I can do it in
couple of lines using snow snow
snowflake ml so it's just simplified
stuff but basically it's doing exactly
the same thing but pushing down
platforms try happens platform side in
this case a lot of operations like
future engine can be pushed down without
entering into pandas what we were
talking about so it's it's also approach
to give people an option to choose what
they want to work with either with SQL
with pandas with data frames train
outside train inside or maybe use
pre-trained models we are having it's
your choice but generally it should be
easy for people um available yeah so
this is a this will create a snowflake
ml linear regression model uh but if you
will check check it under the hood
basically it will do exactly the same
thing like we did the couple lines above
so it will convert create dump and so on
so but it's just simple simpler you
don't need to write a lot of code and
achieve the same result but at the end
you can just convert it to psychic learn
object and work it as a normal psychic
learn
model and so there's a couple of uh
extra statistics about uh coefficients
variable coefficients and so
on uh you can view the model that is
stored on the stage and so on but let's
move further just to not I already pass
the time but I'm I'm just finishing so
next one so I have the model everything
is strain so I need to create the user
defined function to score to to uh do
the model
inference so what I will be doing what
I'm doing here I'm declaring the the the
function uh actually two functions load
model and linear regression predict
local sales it will be using data frame
so it will not run row by row during the
scoring you you can pass hund like
thousand of rows to it and it will
return return thousand of rows uh in
return so you it's it's it will run much
faster basically so this this function
loads the model do the prediction and
return the results so it's pretty simple
function uh again I need to register it
as the uh permanent user defined
function and I can do the prediction I
don't want to wait so I want to scale up
my warehouse to medium so make to run it
faster and I can just use this train
Snow Park The F select and call UDF over
here to do the actual prediction and if
we go over here to check the SQL
statement you can see
here is my function inside plane SQL so
you can use this function in plain SQL
in Tableau or powerbi or DB Weaver
anywhere basically can you quickly
explain what is the difference between
the spr before any right now yeah the
espro is just a pure python code
executed on the on the sandbox on the
python sandbox it's pure python it's
it's a few operations happening as one
execution so you bule operations
together to train the model the feature
engineering whatever do the pipelines
and in the end the outcome of that
stroke would be a file that can be
registered as a UDF so UDF is basically
something that's much more digestible
for users of the platform and it can be
tabular UDF it can be vectorized UDF or
can be scalar UDF it really depends how
you how you design it and what is the
need behind
it yeah so
maybe let's not go yeah deeper yeah so
this is the exactly the same thing that
you can do I will not run it using the
snowflake LM ml so you can just run LM
predict uh LM is the model that I train
above using snowflake ML and at at the
end you can do the evaluation but
basically it creates of course the same
results the snowflake ML and psyit
because it's it's the same code under
the hood at the end you can uh visualize
it on the map
for example those results uh if you want
to predict and you can use various of
tools for it and one of the tools and
this is the really last thing I want to
present is uh something that is called
uh stream lead so it's a pretty nice uh
python Library open source python
library that can be used to create
simply create visualization it it uses
some something that is called widgets
widgets are the elements type part of
the visualization uh it's the elements
that that you will visualize in the app
so as you can see you can use the St
right to write the text h St liner chart
to create the chart and the elements
will be interactive but what how it's
connect to snowflake first of all
snowflake bought stream lead but it's
still remains open source as the part
but the second second thing that is
really relevant is that you can execute
those streamlit application inside
Snowflake and uh tasty by forecast over
here so you don't need to provision the
infrastructure you don't need to create
the environment to to to create it you
can write your own P snow stream lead
application inside Snowflake and run it
let's run it maybe for waro or
k waro you can create the shift pick up
the shift and just update and create the
the running application inside sowl so
it's snowlake have multiple purposes you
can use it for many different things
including hosting the hosting the
application so right now as you can see
it's a normal interactive map hosted on
inside Snowflake and what what what is
coming as well is that you will be able
to monetize that application inside
snowflake Marketplace so you can create
your own applications or your own data
listings and sell it and monetize it
inside snowflake
ecosystem uh
so that's it from my
side yes how do
you because
you ex
large system how it
works the question is how it works yeah
how do you because like everyone work
Partners know that it's not seconds to
and this is snowflake magic no there is
no magic unfortunately so snowflake is
keeping something that is called hot
pool of the
machines we have we have thousands
generally We Are One of the biggest
consumers of aure and AWS I think
comparable to Netflix and everything
that you find as large companies so we
are paying for them but not the
customers customers only pays for them
when they turn it on we have we have a
pool of thousands of virtual machines
and when you spin up the
cluster these machines from the pool are
allocated to your name space and then
when you turn it down it goes back to
the pool and it's going through a pool
which is kind of destroying the hard
memory for that so which
part
connectors so what was the question
which part of the snowflake are open
source which part of snowflake are open
source that's a difficult question
because snowflake is not open source as
I said stream lead is a kind of library
that is open source data frame standard
connectors connectors libraries I'm not
sure connectors stream lead uh I think
iceberg is open source yeah and we are
contributing to that so iceberg is the
Delta killer parts of those but for
example if you would if you would be I
don't know a freelancer or would
represent the company and you've created
a kind of storage procedure that
requires very abstract kind of data set
I know for retail exam for example and
an input would be uh customer Story Time
serious uh you can expose the strog on
Marketplace as wer said which means that
every other customer of snowflake can
buy this spr for you and for example
train their model because you've created
a very Universal kind of a logic for
training a model so voice laab can can
sell your your tuned llms inside
Snowflake and actually we are working on
with one of the Polish partner that
is right now uh doing the private
preview for monetizing the in
Marketplace is having logic which are
udfs in strokes but also having data for
example I don't know Master Card can
sell you information if you're a
retailer what are the segments that are
buying using the card and how the
transactions are going Vision sales data
about Harbor fact set is selling
information about what is happening on
the stock market so every customer of
snow is interconnected it's a large web
and that logic that seems to be
interesting you can contribute you can
expose it for free you may decide like
this is the code on G it's for free you
want to use it and contribute or you can
try to monetize it
so so sake itself is simple question not
everything is open source yeah but there
are elements of that are yeah and
snowflake is contributing to a couple of
projects as well so if you are really
interested into and want to learn more
feel invited you will not be invited
ined anymore feel invited to build local
this biggest event that we are
organizing in our region it will be
hosted in warso Because by the way one
of the uh creator of snowflake is Polish
yeah Martin zukoski and he is creator of
of snowflake snow snowflake have the
third biggest we are fighting for the
second but right now it's third biggest
R&D centers in the whole world located
in Warsaw so we have a little bit of
Polish Roots inside the company so if
you are interested
uh this is the engineering uh conference
it's not like the marketing uh we are
doing marketing conference at the
beginning of the year this one is we are
aiming for engineers data scientists
there will be a Hands-On workshops uh
streaming uh Workshop as well there will
be additional things about snow park and
so on so feel invited question there few
sessions about L
exactly no questions okay let's WRA
right so let's
thank pizza is ready so feel free to
grab a bite